have you ever heard of a game called
werewolf no everyone gets a piece of
paper it's either got villager written
on it but two have the word werewolf
someone runs the game to make sure no
one's cheating and they go okay it's
night time everyone close your eyes
werewolves choose someone to kill and
the werewolves go they say okay everyone
close your eyes it's morning time open
them again during the night Francis was
killed there's then a conversation and
this is where it gets interesting
between all the villagers and the two
werewolves over who the werewolves are
then at the end of the day the the
villagers have to decide who they're
going to kill and they say well we're
going to kill Constantin it's revealed
by the person running the game I'm
afraid Constantin was a villager and the
game continues the villagers win the
game if they kill both werewolves the
werewolves win the game if they kill all
but two villagers and the werewolves
usually win the game was invented by a
student of Sociology in Russia who
wanted to prove his thesis that an
uninformed majority will always lose a
battle of information against an
informed minority so that just shows
when you have hidden information you can
completely manipulate a large group of
people